lance ready to go just off the injured
list of a big start for lance
considering we were winding down only a
dozen games to go here's isaiah connor
falefa best hitter this year on the
texas rangers taking this one back past
lance mccullars but there's al tube
making the play on the move nice throw
altuve
gets the last two outs kyle gibson this
evening who is making his tenth start
you can see that college year has not
gone exactly the way that he had hoped
that batting average near 300 105 record
own one the runner goes the pitch inside
the throw to second the tag and springer
is out good throw by jeff mathis and a
nice tag by rugnet odor
springer is nailed at second base and
the bases are clear now with one out for
altuve
two men on and two outs here for tucker
it takes strike three called
and gibson gets the benefit maybe of a
pitchers strike right there lance versus
joey gallo
as gallow continues to not fare well
against lance six straight strikeouts in
his career
back-to-back strikeouts for lance
mccullars he's starting to spin that
snapdragon a little bit here's anderson
tajeda young shortstop with a runner on
second and two out and he goes down
swinging as lance mccullar strikes out
three in the inning josh reddick
left-handed hitter
comebacker gibson has it
plenty of time to make that little toss
over to first and it's a one two three
bottom of the second tuve is on for
brantley
at one and two the count of brantley
and this pitch is pulled to the right
side to roogie out in shallow right he
picks it up quick release and brantley
is thrown out here to end the third
tucker now struck out looking in the
first inning
this one looped out to right long run
gallow and he'll lay himself out to make
the catch
it's a big dude going down hard to make
that grab
two away
short flight ball sinking pretty quickly
and joey decides to almost play it safe
go ahead and dive for it instead of
trying to catch it on the run you get
caught in between aldonado he's struck
out in the third inning 3-2 pitch and
that is strike three called he gets
maldonado looking
for his fourth strikeout of the night
neither pitcher has given up much
tonight but lance especially strong
euler goes down and makes a nice
backhanded play to lance covering
lance gets a lot of ground outs he leads
the league in put outs and that's why he
covers a lot on the right side julie
made a nice play there
in on his hands slowly hit to bregman
alex makes the play to first and there's
two groundouts here in the sixth inning
calhoun has popped up and struck out
tonight there it is curveball
popped up carlos correa with the easy
play lance walks off
six innings of shutout baseball so far
springer has singled and pumped out to
second base
he strikes out springer looking
for his fifth punch out tonight altuve
has been on base twice once with a walk
and once with what was scored in infield
single gets him to chase strike three
and that's back-to-back strikeouts in
fact go back to last inning that's three
straight for gibson michael brantley is
coming up next
and that one was hit on the ground
behind first backhanded by guzman in
foul territory but it's a fair ball one
two three inning gibson has retired ten
in a row
there's solace
on the ground bregman cuts it off in
front of correa makes the off-balance
throw gets solace by a half step lance
mccullers seven innings of two-hit
shutout baseball here's kyle tucker
on the ground into the shift and past
the shortstop taheda thought he was
gonna make that play but it got beyond
him and into the outfield another
scratch hit if it is rule to hit where
the infield did not help the pitcher
runner going throw down to second is
high the tag almost got him tucker with
his sixth stolen base of the year let's
see if that hand gets in there oh i
don't know
you take a chance here why not the
challenger the rangers will i think he's
out yeah i think he is out
there we go
with not much fanfare
a 1-1 to guriel
and this one flared out to second odor
is there and the inning is done gibson's
been dealing tonight
and the one-two springer swings and
misses strike three and gibson gets
through eight scoreless innings in
houston tonight i'm joey galloway hitler
so far tonight one-two pitch gallow hits
this one out toward right field that
could be trouble it gets down and that's
a base hit here comes tavares he'll
score
gallow to second base on the automatic
double and the rangers take a
one-nothing lead of the ninth
kyle gibson going back out for the ninth
hit el tuve a single struck out and walk
two
that strike three called he gets altuve
looking for the first out of the ninth
and now michael brantley to strike pitch
strike three called he gets brantley
looking for the second out of the inning
so here we go tying run at second and a
very good young hitter in kyle tucker
coming to the plate and that one lined
up first in the ball game is over
and the gamble works for chris woodward
he sticks with his veteran starter and
he gets the shutout tonight a
one-nothing rangers win